das ist wirklich paradox obwohl die
meere eigentlich immer wärmer werden hat
ein us forschungsteam jetzt eine region
der erde aufgespürt die immer kälter
wird konkret geht es um die tiefen des
pazifischen ozeans dort wird das wasser
unterhalb von 2000 metern tiefe immer
kälter was die kleinen eiszeit damit zu
tun hat und warum dieses ergebnis
bedeutet dass es höchste zeit ist unsere
aktuellen klimamodelle zu überarbeiten
erfahrt ihr jetzt bei klicks um
science-fiction
hier gibt es täglich verblüffendes
science videos abonniert den kann da nur
dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
die auswertung historischer messung
enthüllte das überraschende phänomen
ganz im gegensatz zu dem temperatur
trend auf der erdoberfläche und in den
oberen regionen der meere wird es im
tiefen pazifik kälte und zwar um 0,02
grad pro jahrhundert so ein us
forschungsteam in einer aktuellen studie
die erklärung für dieses ergebnis
liefern die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler gleich mit schuld ist
wohl die sogenannte kleine eiszeit auf
die das wasser in der pazifischen
tiefsee mit einer verzögerung von
mehreren jahrhunderten reagiert aber von
vorne die kleine eiszeit herrschte
zwischen 1250 und 1900 auf der
nordhalbkugel vorher war das thema eher
warm so dass sogar die menschen in
norwegen getreide anbauen konnten doch
dann gab es einen umschwung extremwinter
sorgten dafür dass sogar die themse in
london und die kanäle in den
niederlanden zugefroren waren viele
menschen starben
denn es herrschen hungersnöte und
seuchen bei der kleinen eiszeit handelt
es sich im gegensatz zu der klimatischen
entwicklung heutzutage allerdings um
eine natürliche variation des klimas und
wurde nicht durch die menschen
vorangetrieben von dieser kälte ist
tatsächlich etwas geblieben und zwar im
pazifischen ozean seinen tiefen wasser
reagiert also erst jetzt jahrhunderte
später auf die kleine eiszeit
zurückzuführen ist dies wohl auf die
sehr langsame zirkulation der
wassermassen innerhalb des pazifischen
ozeans dazu die forscherin jbi die an
der untersuchung beteiligt war
diese gewässer sind so alt und seit so
langer zeit nicht mehr an der oberfläche
gewesen
sie erinnern sich quasi noch daran was
vor hunderten von jahren geschah als
europa einige der kältesten winter der
geschichte erlebte bei ihrer analyse
griff das forschungsteam auf messungen
aus den 1800 70er jahren zurück und
vergleicht diese mit aktuelleren
messdaten aus den 1990 er jahren doch um
falsche ergebnisse auszuschließen
mussten die fachleute einige
fehlmessungen aus den 1800 70er jahren
korrigieren damals fand die weltweit
erste moderne expedition statt um den
meeresboden und die ozeane systematisch
unter die lupe zu nehmen und zwar an
bord der hms challenger von der aus
insgesamt 5000 temperaturmessungen
durchgeführt wurden die damals
angewandte methode war nicht nur ein
riesiger arbeitsaufwand sondern gilt
heutzutage als längst überholt einzelne
thermometer wurden damals an seilen ins
wasser abgelassen um dann die temperatur
abzulesen
dazu peter huber von der harvard
university wir haben diese historischen
daten auf abweichungen überprüft und
eine vielzahl von korrekturen
durchgeführt dabei ging es um aspekte
wie druck einflüsse auf die thermometer
und dehnungs effekte bei den hanfseilen
die zum absenken der thermometer genutzt
wurden am ende zeigte der vergleich der
temperaturmessung von heute und damals
aber das was das forschungsteam auch
schon in seinem modell vermutet hatte
große teile des pazifiks sind in einer
tiefe von 2000 metern abgekühlt die
wassermassen darüber dagegen erwärmen
sich anders dagegen sieht es im atlantik
aus dort hat sich auch das tiefenwasser
seit den 800 70er jahren erwärmt und
spiegelt somit die klimaerwärmung in den
letzten jahrhunderten wieder
laut der aktuellen studie findet zwar
auch hier eine verzögerung zwischen
tiefsee und oberfläche statt allerdings
liegt sie im atlantik wohl nur bei einem
bis vier jahrhunderten dazu die
erklärung der wissenschaftler und
wissenschaftlerinnen die pazifischen
tiefenwasser haben wegen ihrer stärkeren
isolation von der oberfläche ein
längeres gedächtnis als der atlantik so
können das im pazifik 800 bis 1400 jahre
dauern ehe sich auch in wassertiefen von
mehr als zwei kilometern die
temperaturveränderungen der oberfläche
niederschlagen das ergebnis macht
deutlich das klima zustände sehr lange
ihre spuren in den gewässern
hinterlassen
genauso spannend ist aber der einfluss
der ozeane auf das heutige klima denn
klar ist dass diese als ein wichtiger
klima puffer im klimawandel fungieren
denn sie nehmen sowohl co2 als auch
wärme aus der atmosphäre auf doch die
neuen studienergebnisse machen deutlich
dass die oberen wassermassen des
pazifiks nicht so viel wärme aufgenommen
haben wie bisher angenommen wurde
somit wäre seine puffer wirkung kleiner
als gedacht was bedenklich ist dieses
ergebnis erfordert also auch das
aktuelle klimamodelle angepasst werden
müssen umfassend könnt ihr euch übrigens
über den klimawandel bei raumzeit block
der zukunft informieren dafür hier
klicken auf das video klimawandel fakt
oder fiktion unbedingt ansehen und
natürlich unbedingt abonnieren ansonsten
bis dann bleibt dran